hi i'm
peter parker
spider-man has his spidey sense and tom
holland has his improv sense you might
think that there wouldn't be much room
for improv on the giant blockbuster
movies tom has worked on such as
avengers infinity war and uncharted but
you would be wrong these are the scenes
and moments where tom holland took
matters into his own hands and showcased
his impeccable improv skills we
improvised the version of the scene
which wasn't great but it sparked an
idea number one
the relationship between tony stark and
peter parker is one of the most
endearing in all of the mcu robert
downey jr and tom holland have such a
great chemistry on set that makes their
scenes together almost effortless as
they flow so naturally a great example
of this is at the beginning of
spider-man homecoming when tony and
peter are in the car together tony leans
over peter to open the door for him
which peter takes as an awkward attempt
at a hug the embrace was improvised by
holland and the ever professional downey
went right along with it i just thought
it would be funny if i hugged him this
unscripted moment led to one of the most
satisfying payoffs in avengers endgame
when peter finally got that hug from
tony
oh this is nice
number two
tom holland's nathan drake and mark
wahlberg's victor sullivan worked
extremely well together in the
live-action movie adaptation of the
uncharted video game director ruben
flusher gave the two actors a lot of
room to go off script and just used
their natural banter to create the
relationship of the characters i have
lots of fond memories of improvising
with mark it develops into this real
bond and this true reliance on each
other while tom holland stated it was a
ton of fun he hasn't shied away about
admitting how daunting it was to put
himself in such a vulnerable position
any time you improvise and it's not
funny it's horrible
number three
everyone remembers the emotions they
felt when they first watched avengers
infinity war and experienced the
heartbreaking scene of peter dusting
away in tony's arms it was such a
powerful scene driven by the incredible
performance of tom holland this moment
was largely improvised by holland who
said that joe russo simply told him to
act like he didn't want to go away and
that spawned holland's tear-jerking i
don't want to go i don't want to go turn
please the reason tom repeats the line
over and over is because it's one of his
processes as an actor when he needs to
cry he picks a line and constantly
repeats it until the tears start flowing
it seems to be getting easier and i i
cry
like watching films now all the time
number four
seeing the three spider-man altogether
on the same screen for the first time
was an incredible moment the rooftop
scene was a perfect blend of the old and
the new coming together what makes it
even better is the fact that a majority
of the scenes between tom holland toby
maguire and andrew garfield were
improvised and there was so much fun
improv with those guys
it was the most incredible experience of
my career
number five
tom holland flexed his dramatic acting
muscles in 2021's cherry a film directed
by the russo brothers who also directed
tom in avengers infinity war and end
game there wasn't as much room for
improvisation in this film but there was
one scene in particular when holland and
co-star ciara bravo were able to go off
script the moment saw the two lie down
together and fall asleep well after the
original scene was supposed to end the
russos are very good at creating a very
fun atmosphere on set so you know we
were always able to kind of step away
from the emotion number six
the three webslingers were like old
friends on set despite never meeting
each other previously their genuine love
and respect for one another inspired the
beautiful moment at the end of no way
home when the three spider-men say
goodbye with a hug the end of the film
is us having this moment where i'm like
thank you so much i really appreciate it
and then we have this beautiful hugs in
between takes of the rooftop scene on
top of the school tom went up to andrew
and toby and thanked them for their
involvement in the film at the end of
their discussion they hugged each other
we all embraced and we all started
crying which director john watts and
producer amy pascal saw yep that's how
we're gonna end the film
they immediately knew they needed to
include the moment in the film and the
rest is history
number seven
tony stark's demise in endgame was an
extremely emotional scene we won
mr stark
and for obvious reasons a big secret
there were only a handful of actors on
set that day including tom holland he
revealed that the scene when everyone is
saying their goodbyes was almost 100
improvised when we shot that scene with
robert there was no real script the
actors were told what was happening in
the scene and given a general idea of
what the directors wanted the rest was
up to them it was a really emotional day
and
i mean looking back on it now it was
maybe the craziest day i've ever had on
say
number eight
spider-man far from home features a very
slapstick scene when the first elemental
shows up we see peter repeatedly bong
his head against a giant bell in a tower
it's a very comical scene and it all
comes from tom and his brother harry
banging into the thing and then sliding
and then banging into it again yeah that
was that was awesome the brothers came
up with the sequence shot it on their
phone and then showed it to director
john watts who liked it enough to
include it in the film
i liked it like cuts out wide and you
just hear that
number nine all peter parker wants to do
is help out his fellow avengers and all
tony stark wants him to do is stay out
of their troubles that dynamic led to a
very simple yet funny exchange in
avengers infinity war when doctor
strange and tony are discussing their
sticky situation peter chimes in with
i'm back up no you're still away the
adults are talking downey immediately
responded with his own improvised line
once again showcasing the two actors
impeccable chemistry
number 10
the mcu's friendly neighborhood
spider-man was introduced in captain
america civil war where we first see him
interacting with tony stark this first
interaction is largely improvised by the
two actors what are you what are you
what are you doing here it's about time
we met
let me get my emails right
yeah
and it's probably because the two did
such an amazing job during tom's
audition when they played through a
version of the scene we see in the film
and also improvised even though tom was
warned not to
number eleven
the robert downey jr and tom holland
moments just keep coming in the same
scene when peter first meets tony stark
the two have a meeting in peter's room
when tony goes to sit down next to peter
he asks him i'm gonna sit here so you
move the leg
director anthony russo revealed that
this part of the scene was improvised
number 12. tom and zendaya work so well
together and are the best spider-man mj
duo although zendaya thinks tom can be a
little much when it comes to all the
improv he does with her still their
chemistry together made for great scenes
as their improv added an important layer
to the character's dynamic
you should i um everyone goes on how
good at improvising me
number 13.
did you know that in far from home peter
and mysterio's relationship was
originally supposed to be much more
contentious they were going to butt
heads and have a more antagonistic
relationship even before mysterio was
revealed as the villain however tom and
jake gyllenhaal got along too well off
camera bonding and forming a chemistry
that ultimately affected their on-screen
characters john watts rolled with the
dynamic and allowed the two to playfully
improvise in multiple scenes
number 14
marisa tome is yet another actor tom
holland had improvised scenes with one
of these was the restaurant scene in
spider-man homecoming their conversation
where aunt may repeated the word larb
was totally improvised and you can
actually see tom holland start to crack
his smile luckily the camera cuts away
before he completely breaks
number 15
ned battallon and tom holland became
instant best friends on the set of
spider-man for the first film homecoming
the duo apparently weren't given their
scripts days in advance so when it came
time to film they didn't know all their
lines and just improvised instead these
improvised moments prove that he is a
talent worthy of playing such high
profile characters like spider-man which
unscripted moment was your favorite let
us know in the comments and thanks for
stopping by at the things
[Music]